Muhammad Ali was the greatest . . . name . . . for
a slave master . . . ever.
In 1964, a young boxer named Cassius Clay
won an upset victory over Sonny Liston and
became heavyweight champion of the world.
Later that year, Clay changed his name, first
to Cassius X, then to Muhammad Ali.
Why did he change his name?
Let’s let him answer.
Why don’t you like to be called “Clay”
anymore?
Oh, Clay was not my name.
Once we follow the belief, hear the . . . understand
the teachings of the Honorable Elijah Muhammad,
and come into a knowledge of ourselves that
we want to be called after names of our people,
which are names to fit us black people.
And Clay was a white man’s name.
It was a slave name.
And I’m no longer Clay.
I’m no longer a slave.
So now I’m Muhammad Ali.
So, Clay was a white man’s name, but “Muhammad”
and “Ali” were names for his people.
We want to be called after names of our people.
What people would that be?
Arab slave masters?
Because that’s who Muhammad and his son-in-law
Ali were, according to Muslim sources.
And let’s not forget that Arabs can exhibit
a variety of shades and tones.
Here’s an example of an Arab.
Looking at this picture, you may be wondering,
“Did Opie Taylor grow up and convert to Islam?”
No.
This is Sheikh Muhammad al-Yaqoubi, the 34th
grandson of Muhammad, the prophet of Islam.
This guy’s so white, he tried to buy Go-Gurts
at Whole Foods.
And this is exactly what we would expect,
based on descriptions of Muhammad in Islam’s
most trusted sources.
Sahih al-Bukhari, Number 63:
Narrated Anas bin Malik: While we were sitting
with the Prophet in the mosque, a man came
riding on a camel.
He made his camel kneel down in the mosque,
tied its foreleg and then said:
“Who amongst you is Muhammad?”
At that time the Prophet was sitting amongst
us leaning on his arm.
We replied, “This white man reclining on
his arm.”
Why did Muhammad’s followers refer to him
as “this white man”?
Because he was so white, he took off his shirt
at night, and got a third-degree moon-burn.
Clay was a white man’s name.
Sahih Muslim, Number 6081:
It was narrated that Abu Juhaifah said: “I
saw the Messenger of Allah with a white complexion
and some white hairs.”
What do you call a million Muhammads jumping
out of an airplane?
Snow.
Clay was a white man’s name.
Sahih Muslim 6071:
It was narrated from Al-Jurairi from Abu At-Tufail:
“I said to him: ‘Did you see the Messenger
of Allah?’
He said: ‘Yes, he was white with an elegant
face.’”
Muhammad’s so white, he jumped in a hot
tub, and the water turned into creamer.
Clay was a white man’s name.
The Muslim sources go on and on about Muhammad’s
epic whiteness, telling us about the “whiteness
of his shins,” and the “whiteness of his
thigh,” and the “whiteness of his leg,”
and the “whiteness of his stomach,” and
the “whiteness of his forearms,” and the
“whiteness of his armpits,” and the “whiteness
of his cheeks.”
I hope everyone brought soup, because I just
found the world’s biggest cracker.
We want to be called after names of our people.
White people?
Clay was a white man’s name.
“Muhammad” was a white man’s name.
He was the whitest prophet in history.
Now, how many Muhammads would it take to screw
in a light bulb?
None.
He would just tell one of his more than three-dozen
slaves to do it.
Let’s read about some of these slaves.
Sahih al-Bukhari Number 7263:
Narrated Umar: I went to (the house of the
Prophet) and behold, Allah’s Messenger was
staying in a Mashruba and a black slave of
Allah’s Messenger was at the top of its stairs.
I said to him, “Tell (the Prophet) that
here is Umar bin al-Khattab.”
Then he admitted me.
Sahih al-Bukhari 6161:
Narrated Anas bin Malik:
Allah’s Messenger was on a journey and he
had a black slave called Anjasha, and he was
driving the camels (very fast, and there were
women riding on those camels).
Allah’s Messenger said, “Waihaka, O Anjasha!
Drive slowly the camels with the glass vessels
(i.e., the women)!”
Muhammad was so white, when his black slave
Anjasha needed to beep at him, the horn on
Anjasha’s camel was like, “Honky! Honky!”
Sunan an-Nasa’i, Number 4625:
It was narrated that Jabir said: “A slave
came and gave his pledge to the Messenger
of Allah to emigrate, and the Prophet did
not realize that he was a slave.
Then his master came looking for him.
The Prophet said: ‘Sell him to me.’
So he bought him for two black slaves, then
he did not accept the pledge of anyone after
that until he had asked: ‘Is he a slave?’”
So an Arab man walked up to Muhammad and said,
“I’d like to join you.
Do you accept my pledge?”
Muhammad replied, “Yes.”
But the man turned out to be a slave.
So Muhammad had to buy the slave from his
master, and what did he buy him with?
He bought him with two of his numerous black
slaves.
Apparently, black slaves were only half as
valuable as Arab slaves.
Of course, Muhammad didn’t want to keep
giving up his black slaves, so he decided
to be more careful about taking the pledge.
Notice, by the way, how black slaves are described
in Islam’s most trusted sources.
Trading slaves is equivalent to trading animals.
Here’s one about a black slave who was shot
to death while unloading Muhammad’s luggage.
Sunan an-Nasai 3858:
It was narrated that Abu Hurairah said: “We
were with the Messenger of Allah in the year
of Khaibar, and we did not get any spoils
of war except for wealth, goods, and clothes.
Then a man from Banu Ad-Dubaib, who was called
Rifa’ah bin Zaid, gave the Messenger of
Allah a black slave who was called Mid’am.
The Messenger of Allah set out for Wadi al-Qura.
When we were in Wadi al-Qura, while Mid’am
was unloading the luggage of the Messenger
of Allah, an arrow came and killed him.
The people said: ‘Congratulations!
You will go to Paradise,’ but the Messenger
of Allah said: ‘No, by the One in Whose
hand is my soul!
The cloak that he took from the spoils of war on
the day of Khaibar is burning him with fire.’”
So, Mid’am, one of Muhammad’s many black
slaves, grabbed a cloak before the spoils
were divided after the Battle of Khaybar,
and that earned him a one-way trip to hell.
Hence, according to Muhammad, if you take
something from the spoils of war before the
spoils have been divided, you’re going to
hell, right?
Not so fast.
Let’s read about what happened when Muhammad’s
son-in-law Ali—the “Ali” in Muhammad
Ali’s name—took a slave-girl from the
spoils of war without permission.
Sahih al-Bukhari 4350:
Narrated Buraida: The Prophet sent Ali to Khalid
to bring the Khumus (of the booty) [The “Khumus”
was the portion of the war booty that was
taken directly to Muhammad; Muhammad would
get one-fifth of everything taken as spoils
of war, including sex-slaves], and I hated
Ali, and Ali had taken a bath (after a sexual
act with a slave-girl from the Khumus).
I said to Khalid, “Don’t you see this
(i.e., Ali)?”
When we reached the Prophet, I mentioned that
to him.
He said, “O Buraida!
Do you hate Ali?”
I said, “Yes.”
He said, “Don't hate him, for he deserves
more than that from the Khumus.”
So Ali had sex with a slave-girl from the
spoils designated for Muhammad himself, before
Muhammad decided what to do with his portion
of the spoils, and Muhammad had
no problem with it.
Thus, if you’re a black slave and you take
something from the spoils, you’re going to hell.
If you’re Muhammad’s son-in-law and you
take something from the spoils, no one’s
allowed to question you.
And it’s not like Ali had to steal a sex-slave
from the Khumus, since Muhammad was happy
to give sex-slaves to his favorite companions.
As we read in the History of at-Tabari, Volume
9, page 29:
“From the captives of Hunayn, the Messenger
of God gave Ali ibn Abi Talib a slave girl
called Raytah bint Hilal.”
Like Muhammad, Ali was a slave owner and a
slave trader.
He had both black and Arab slaves.
This means, of course, that when Cassius Clay
changed his name to Muhammad Ali, he was taking
the names of two men who bought, owned, sold,
and traded black African slaves.
We want to be called after names of our people.
Interestingly, when he was growing up, Muhammad
Ali didn’t know much about the name Cassius Clay.
Tell me how you came to get such a Roman name
as that.
Well, as I understand, I’m Cassius Marcellus
Clay VI, and my great-great-grandfather was
a Kentucky slave, and he was named after some
great Kentuckian.
Well, “Cassius Marcellus Clay” is a great
name in Kentucky.
And really, where he was from, or where it
was all originated, I couldn’t tell you, but . . .
He thought it came from some famous Kentuckian.
And he was right about that.
Muhammad Ali was named Cassius Marcellus Clay
Jr.
His father was Cassius Marcellus Clay Sr., who
was named by his father, Herman Heaton Clay.
Why did Herman name his son
“Cassius Marcellus Clay”?
He gave his son that name in honor of the
nineteenth-century Kentucky abolitionist Cassius
Marcellus Clay, who freed the slaves he inherited
from his father and donated the land that
was used to build Berea College, a college
that accepted students of all races from its
founding in 1855.
Clay was the target of repeated assassination
attempts for his calls to end slavery.
A paid assassin named Samuel Brown shot Clay
in the chest at a public debate.
Clay responded by pulling out his Bowie knife
and cutting out Brown’s eyes.
He was later ambushed by six brothers with
knives and a gun; Clay fought all of them
off and killed one of the brothers with his
Bowie knife.
Clay published an anti-slavery newspaper,
called “True American.”
When he began receiving death-threats for
his paper, he bought two canons, pointed them
towards the entrance of the printing office,
and said, “Come and get me.”
After the Civil War started, Abraham Lincoln
sent Clay as the U.S. ambassador to Russia.
Clay convinced the Tsar, Alexander II, to
threaten Great Britain and France into not
recognizing or supporting the Confederate
States.
When Clay returned to America, Lincoln offered
him the position of Major General in the army.
Clay told Lincoln that he would only accept
the post if Lincoln publicly proclaimed the
emancipation of all slaves in the Confederate
States, so that a Northern victory would ensure
their freedom.
Lincoln investigated the proposition and issued
the Emancipation Proclamation.
That’s who Muhammad Ali was originally named
after.
He was named after the Kentucky abolitionist
who helped convince Lincoln to issue
the Emancipation Proclamation.
But Ali didn’t want that name.
So he was given the name “Muhammad” by
Elijah Muhammad.
Now it would be one thing for Ali to say,
“Well, I just don’t want a name that was
ever associated with any white person or that
was ever associated with any slave owner,”
in which case it would make sense to reject
the name Cassius Clay.
But if that’s his reasoning, what sense
did it make to change his name to Muhammad,
in honor of the white prophet with black slaves?
And there’s a lesson here for all of us.
When we don’t know history, when we become
ignorant of history, there will always be
someone waiting to step in and take advantage
of our ignorance.
Muhammad Ali was sick to death of white people
using black people.
Muslim preachers took that resentment, and
the resentment of an entire community, and
used it to spread the teachings of a man whose
followers institutionalized black African
slavery more than a thousand years before
the United States even existed.
Now think about this.
How long did the transatlantic slave trade
last?
About three centuries.
The first shipment of slaves from Africa to
Brazil was in 1526.
The last country in the Americas to outlaw
the transatlantic slave trade was Brazil in 1831.
So it was illegal to ship slaves to the Americas
after 1831.
People could still own slaves, but the transatlantic
trade was abolished.
Slavery didn’t last a century in the United
States, once the United States had formed
as a nation.
We remember the horrors of slavery very clearly,
because it wasn’t that long ago.
We have photographs.
People wrote about it.
A war was fought over it.
Now if just about everything most of us know
about slavery comes from a fairly brief period
of history (a few centuries), how much do
you think there is to learn about slavery
in the Muslim world, where the slave trade
has lasted nearly fourteen centuries—from
the time of Muhammad right down to the present?
It’s still going on in Africa.
So Islam continues to take advantage of black
men and black women by enslaving them, in
areas where slavery continues to this day.
But even in areas where slavery has been abolished,
Islam still takes advantage of black men and
black women, by lying to them and convincing
them to spread the message of Islam, because,
as we all know, Islam is against slavery and
racial injustice.
That’s why Muhammad called Ethiopians “raisin
heads” and said that Satan looks like a
black man.
Notice, as far as Islam is concerned, if you’re
black, you’re either going to serve Islam
by being a slave, or you’re going to serve Islam
by converting to Islam and spreading Islam.
Either way, you’re serving Islam.
Why is that?
Well, the Qur’an says that Muhammad is the
pattern of conduct for Muslims.
And as far as Muhammad was concerned, if you
were black, you were either going to serve
Islam by being a slave, or you were going
to serve Islam by converting to Islam and
spreading Islam.
Either way, you were serving Islam.
Virtually everyone who was anywhere near Africa
has used black men, women, and children to
serve their own agendas.
But no ideology has ever taken advantage of
black men and black women more than Islam—
so much so that, even today, if a world-class
black athlete happens to be named after a
white abolitionist and decides to change his
name to Muhammad, the whitest prophet in history,
whose followers continue buying, selling,
trading, and using black men, women, and children,
the world will praise him for having the courage
to change his name and for setting such a
wonderful example for others.
Muhammad Ali was the greatest heavyweight
boxer of all time.
As a boxer, he was brilliant.
As a historian, not so much.